I'm about to work out but I need to show
you this thing that I got that makes
working out you know I was just gonna
say it makes the workout easier it
doesn't actually make the workout easier
just makes what I do during the workout
easier who needs any extra movement when
you're already moving that body you know
already pump it away I'm so sorry let me
show you okay so this is the little
Gadget you just open it up and it's this
little ring so I wear it like this pay
attention to my phone
are you getting it sometimes you get so
into your workout that like a scroll
it's too much that's too much effort I'm
not scrolling click click now if you'll
excuse me I have dog videos to cry at
more products to be influenced to buy
and all these specific relatable content
to ingest so bye